the pro-abortion movement sent its best
and brightest to capitol hill yesterday
to defend the practice at its most
imperiled moment
and it turns out that the pro-abortion
best and brightest are not particularly
bright
so abortion should be allowed then by
your definition for any reason for any
purpose at any stage right
i trust people to make decisions about
their body and then when relevant i
think that they need to consult their
medical
practitioners okay and not if it is
listen let me just ask you this question
if it is not lawful and morally
acceptable to take the life of a
ten-year-old child i assume you agree
with that right that would be wrong
correct
i believe that okay and a two-year-old
child same thing that would be murder we
would all agree that's wrong then what
is the principal distinction between the
human being that is two years old or
nine months old or one week old or an
hour old than one that is eight inches
further up the birth canal in the uterus
what's the difference why is it okay in
the latter case and not the former cases
i trust people to determine what to do
with their own body wow
full stop
full stop i
uh
uh trust bodies full stop that woman's
name is amy arambidae
she is a professional abortion activist
that woman has a degree in philosophy
from the university of texas
she graduated from law school she has
worked
her entire career in the abortion
industry specifically in public affairs
defending abortion
and when she is confronted with even the
most basic objection to abortion the
best defense she can muster is
i trust people to use their bodies beep
boop beep boop
so
embarrassing and it's not even her fault
it's not even her fault this chickie is
probably among the best and brightest in
the abortion industry the problem is not
her lack of polish the problem is that
she is being asked to defend the
indefensible
this was so
hilariously pathetic yesterday on
capitol hill
it was sad
that there are people who have devoted
their entire lives to defending
infanticide that that is sad
but it was really funny that at the at
the moment where it all matters at the
moment where roe v wade could be
overruled the abortion industry they've
got to get it all together and take
their absolute best shot to defend
abortion they've got absolutely nothing
it wasn't just that lady amy a rambi day
there's another woman an actual
abortionist her name is yeshika robinson
she was asked also by this hero
congressman mike johnson did an
absolutely incredible job
really really excellent stuff grilling
these people she was asked
when does a baby become human here's her
answer
you're not going to answer this question
but how about this one how does one
qualify as fully human
what makes a human being
what makes a person a human being is
them being born number one that's why we
have birthdays
what makes a human this is this is the
highest level of philosophical
sophistication from the abortion
movement
what makes a human being a human
is when they're born that's why we have
birthdays
that's why we have birthday is it now i
thought we had birthdays to commemorate
the day when you were born to
commemorate your birth
birthdays are not called becoming human
days
that the two have nothing to do with one
another and by the way birthdays can be
fungible
people can induce labor sometimes people
go into labor a little bit earlier they
can delay when they give birth to some
degree maybe you were supposed to be
born on the 15th but they actually
induce your delivery on the 13th
or maybe it takes a little bit longer
and it's on the 16th
you're telling me that the ontological
change when you become human
is determined by when you pass through
eight inches of of a lady's body
or not even what if what if you're not
born naturally what if you what if
you're
born through cicero or what if you're
delivered through a cesarean section
does that change things
do you does the magical thing that
happens when you are pushed out of the
woman
when you're pushed out of your mother
does that does that magical thing happen
when you're cut out of the woman's
abdomen by a doctor
of course not this is insane thinking
when do you become i made this point on
the show the other day but i think it's
important to reiterate
very often the pro-abortion movement
will try to say well look we don't
obviously when a baby is born that's a
human being entitled to all the rights
of human beings
uh but when a baby is still in the womb
they don't have all those rights for
some reasons and they'll try to come to
some
arbitrary line at which you become a
human well when you've got all your
fingers when you've got all your toes
when you develop your eyeballs when your
heart is more recognizably beating
that's when you become a human
that doesn't make very much sense to me
one because some people are born without
their fingers some people are born
without their toes some people are born
without those distinguishing features
some people lose it along the way in
their lives if they have an injury are
you telling me they lose their humanity
there no of course not the difference
between having partially formed fingers
and fully formed fingers
is is
a much more trivial distinction than the
difference between
being alive and not being alive we know
even the abortion movement will admit
when a baby is conceived
that baby is alive has all the
characteristics of life
and that baby is a human a distinct
human not a dog not a cat not a giraffe
a human being not a tadpole even if it
looks a little bit like a tadpole it's a
human being
don't you think that the distinction
between
human and not human the distinction
between alive and not alive
is more significant than the distinction
between
his fingers are a little bit bigger now
and not don't you think it's more
important than the distinction she's
making between
you're eight inches up the birth canal
to your eight inches out of the birth
canal hey there i'm glad you like that
clip now what is required is that you
ring that smash that like that hit that
subscribe do the
hit the gizmo do the thing you get the
notifications also head on over to apple
podcast spotify stitch or google play
wherever you get your audio podcasts
subscribe to the michael knowles show
leave a five star review maybe more if
you feel so inclined we'll see you next
time
[Music]
[Music]
you